yeah
hello Steve Kaufman here today I'm going
to talk about Russian my experience with
Russian about how i learned the language
some comments about the language and i'm
going to begin by explaining a bit about
Russia and Russian culture as I perceive
it
i had mentioned in my video about
learning French that the French like to
be very logical at least that's what
they teach at school and they like to be
very precise and how they you know
explain themselves and so forth
the Japanese is not at all that way and
also there's a lot of understatement in
Japanese they don't say no they say you
know we're going to certainly consider
your suggestion which means no
the Russians are not like that the
Russians say no if it's not this you
know they also very much like I mean all
people generalize but in Russia there's
no political correctness there is just
generalizations
they say anything store all good now as
they say in Russian they'll say anything
based on knowing the subject not knowing
the subject getting the facts wrong
I hear this all the time on Echo must be
the most amazing statements with but
with tremendous drama and conviction and
so I'm going to do the same i'm going to
make a very generalized statements about
Russia and Russians without worrying too
much about my facts
so I how do i get started well I was
about 60 and I had really two reasons
for getting into Russian one was that I
had read you know books by dostoevsky
and told stories when I was 17 18 and I
thought it'd be really cool to be able
to read those books in the original and
the second thing was that you know my
approach to language learning is to
de-emphasize grammar not to ignore
grammar but they're not put it up front
and to focus on exposing myself to the
language through lots of listening and
reading and and emphasizing really you
know noticing patterns rather than
complicated grammar rules explanations
and so forth and I was sort of challenge
and said what you can do that with
Russian because the room at the grammar
is too complicated
ok the grammar is very complicated
russian is a difficult language and to
some extent
some people say no language is more
difficult blah blah blah
in fact some languages are more
difficult than others it all depends on
the language that you're starting from
of course but for people without any
background in Slavic Languages Russian
is difficult and i'm going to explain
why but before that i'll talk a little
bit about Russia Russia is is a
phenomenal country
I mean the scale the size of Russia is
mind-boggling
and if we go back in history will see
that you know whatever it was that
Duchess not sure you tomorrow whatever
was Muscovy it was this little area up
in northern Russia where people of i
guess a mixture of Slavic and you know
finish type people and baltic type
people and so forth they were up there
doing their thing
I can't remember whether they were
actually a conquered by the by the
Mongol hordes
who
who dominated that you know the mongold
part are hordes that dominated Russia
for 300 years i think they were can't
remember but whatever it was the Prince
up there eventually defeated them and so
really the growth of Russia even other
people in in the sort of area of what's
now the Ukraine that were also Russians
and Kiev is called the mother of all
Russian cities and so forth but they
were very much under the rule of the
Mongols for 300 years
and so this this musket he was up there
and you know interacting with the Baltic
countries and Germans and Swedes and
stuff like that and not very different
perhaps other than that they spoke a
different language but culturally very
much in that sphere and from that it
expanded to the Pacific you know from
the moment they defeated the Mongols I
within a few hundred years they had
expanded south right down to the Caspian
Sea that expanded you know that I think
they reach the Pacific in the late
sixteen hundred and they only overthrew
the Mongol yo cuz it's called in the
late are in the mid 1500 again my
history for you read it you forget it
but roughly
so it has become this this tremendous
continental country and so use you very
much aware of this and of course
subsequent to that under Catherine the
Great and others ours they consolidated
their hold on these central asian areas
and Caucasus you know there's a
significant expansion in the 19th
century south and east
I mean czar's russia was very much an
imperialist power at an imperialist
power on somewhat weak legs because they
expanded too quickly and they were
defeated by the Japanese in 1905 and
from that the whole you know
largely because of the first world war
the Tsarist Empire collapsed and they
had the revolution and became the Soviet
Union
but all of that is still very
international with people from Central
Asia turkic type people
the caucuses with all of their different
languages and cultures some Islamic some
very early Christian and so forth
and of course they were always meddling
in on the western side of the border
since you know participating in the
partition of Poland and chipping away at
romania and and of course is so it's
kind of been involved in all these
different areas it's absolutely
fascinating
and so that's one of the things you
sense with Russia that the scale is just
is just huge and not even now if I
listen to you must be you know there's a
lot of people there with with Georgia
names that are no longer Georgia
so even with the disintegration of the
Soviet empire
you're aware of these influences and now
have a problem with a problem or
whatever there are issues with all the
different minorities within Russia plus
immigration from countries in the former
Soviet Union and stuff so that that's
the world it's a very much a you ragin
world and we have to understand that
they're not just like some European
country that speaks Slavic language all
right
that's my way back round the language ah
yeah
it starts out with as drafts week it
that's like Hello
so in English we say hello it's pretty
easy to say the last drop drafts week
yet
ok there's not a lot of vowels in there
and and all are saying is hello
you know you practice that in front of
the mirror a few times you've got a
clear that you know the expectoration
off the mirror just joking by the way
should go as they say in Russia you know
and of course check has even fewer
vowels
so I kind of think the Slavs wherever
they started from somewhere in
on the plains of the Eurasian steps
there they must have spent a lot of
their time chewing sunflower seeds and
spitting them out to arrive with a
language that has so few vials and so
many things that you can sort of say
through your teeth and and and lips and
not just talking about the way
so but it's an indication that the
pronunciation is not easy and there are
a few little things that are kind of
deceptive like the old if it's not
stressed in a word becomes ah so
toronto is tanta you know because the
old becomes a hot so that makes the
spelling a little bit difficult
so there are some issues with
pronunciation you know getting your
tongue and lips around all these
consonants and getting used to how the
writing system works on the subject of
the writing system
you know compared to learning Chinese
it's easy but in a way it's not easy
because it's very similar
i mean it's it's a almost parallel
alphabet to the Latin alphabet which is
not surprising because he comes from the
Greek alphabet and sort of the Latin
alphabet which in turn comes from the
Phoenician alphabet but there are some
letters that are unique to Russian their
sure and then they have two characters
that both are pronounced sure I can't
tell the difference and I don't really
know and I've never worried about it and
they have a little B flat sign which is
supposed to soften the sounds and stuff
so there's a few little things in there
that you have to get used to
ah but there are some some letters that
look like latin letters and they in fact
are pronounced differently like what
looks like a pea is actually an R and
since it's very much hardwired in our
minds that that's a pee
it takes a while to get over that takes
a while but it eventually happens
so the only advice on the alphabet is to
get started on it
you're going to be able to start reading
with difficulty within a few hours and
then the more you read the better you
get at it
however as I found when I went to check
it's always easier to read in your own
alphabet always so that is always going
to be a bit of a thing that makes
Russian just that little
it more difficult the other thing is
difficult in Russian I i I'm not going
to go through all the different you know
how the language works obviously word
order is an issue word order in Russian
is very flexible and very different in
some ways you know you can say you know
what could be a ok this is this is a
book in English
the Russians don't worry about articles
Etta Kega this book it that nigga to ask
you know if you say I read a book the
book a book
yeah she died you can Evel Knievel
but you can also say yeah he go to tell
you
so that that word order can be shifted
around and that's possible because i
actually had to a lot of the questions
you only can tell it's a question by the
intonation
if you say of us is what this means you
have means to you is of us hist nigga
you have a book
who was his Kega question I don't wanna
get into the French qu'est-ce que si or
ok ok again Portuguese is just as he is
if you have which is kind of easy but
they can shift the words around in the
order because of the case system and now
i'm going to spend a little time on the
three big bug bears in Russian the three
major problems that you have to overcome
the cases
the second one is verbs of motion and
the third one is the aspect of verbs
everything else kind of you can get used
to but those three
I'm still struggling with so this video
I can see it's going to be a little bit
longer than the others but nevertheless
I hope it's worthwhile cases
some people don't know what cases are I
had Latin at school we had to decline
you know
pelham as fast as possible blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah
this piece those are the singular and
plural six cases of the rat Latin
noun Bella meaning war below me
however it's pronounced in Russian there
are six cases not the same Latin has the
pocket of which the Russians don't have
all of the checks to the cases that
concept is quite straightforward in
other words if noun is the subject of a
sentence
I go the book is on the table then it's
in the nominative if you do something to
the book i give the book to you I give
the book now the book is in the
accusative because you've done something
to it if i give the book to you
I be giving it to you dative the
donation give that's the dated then they
have a thing called the prepositional
case which is basically where something
is on the at in the sort of like a
location location.type case in that case
down will have a different ending
and then they have but i forgot the
genitive which means to belong to
something so of the book of the book
would be in the genitive and they have a
thing called the instrumental by the
book
you know by my pen or anything that
implies what instrument was the agent
that you used to do something in that
case I went by car then the car will be
in the instrumental
so those are the cases there are six
cases the endings for example who might
be the accusative for the feminine
it might be the dative for the masculine
and neuter
so the end these kind of shift around
which doesn't help
I and of course you have masculine
neuter and feminine
so you've got all kinds of different
endings that you have to learn that
starts to become a problem the problem
with the cases is that that in as a
general overview the concept is not
difficult but the specific you know
explanations of why we use one case or
another are extremely confusing and if i
were to read you from this book here
picked out you know
for every case there are like a variety
you know here is okay the general case
is used afterwards expressing expressing
measure and quantity that's fine but if
it's one of something
it's the nominative singular if it's two
three or four of something
it's the genitive singular if it's five
or more
it's the genitive plural now if that was
the only rule you have to learn
you can probably deal with it but
there's lots more
you know the gender case is used in a
positive sense to express and
indifferent incomplete and indefinitely
and can be quantity
okay good for you and you go on your own
you know if you go onto the the
accusative you know it's the genitive
case is normally used after negated
verbs in the following instances when
the negation is intensified by another
word
when a part of the sentence is negated
all the stuff i mean of course I don't
know what that means but I have to look
at the examples you know some what are
we
you know the data is used to express the
logical start over lock
I mean it just goes on and on abcdefg
whatever age but I'm you know like the
vast majority of prepositions don't take
the prepositional case they take the
genitive case and the same proposition
will sometimes take the genitive and
sometimes takes the take the accusative
and so it just it's extremely difficult
and the endings the tables have looked
at those tables so many times and you
can kind of have remembered for a day or
two and then it's gone
and even if you understand the
explanations
after lots of examples and i should say
that that this grammar book with all of
its explanations i always use as an
example of our horrible grammar
explanations could be i have another
book that i bought in Moscow which just
has examples and if with enough examples
you can start to see it
however what I found is ultimately you
just have to read and listen
so often that certain phrases start to
sound natural with their enemies
it was much like learning tones in
Chinese trying to remember the
individual pone for each character was
very difficult
but with enough practice you'll
eventually get better and better
ok and I just digress a bit I am a big
proponent of lots of listening and
reading but to get good
eventually you have to do a lot of
speaking I have done a lot of speaking
in Japanese in French even in Chinese
because i used to go to China you know a
month a year when i was in Hong Kong and
attending that Hong Kong or the can't on
trade fair
speaking Chinese all the time is parking
lot of Chinese I haven't spoken a lot of
Russian so I speak
still with a lot of hesitation and and
mistakes eventually got to speak a lot
but you have to also continue listening
and reading so cases
that's number one you're always in my
view going to have trouble with the
cases perhaps someone who attends a
class was studying it formally maybe
does better than i did i was spending an
hour a day most of it in my car while
exercising listening
it was you know it's it's an interesting
it's not I'm not passing a test
however i must say that given that i
spent five years at an hour a day
a lot of people who study it very
seriously in class and that don't get as
far along as I did
and besides which I can understand so
much and this is another thing when you
don't understand you don't know the
cases it doesn't prevent you from
understanding if you have the words some
things remain a little bit fuzzy but
it's sufficiently redundant the whole
context is that you can still understand
learn words on link where i learned all
my words and enjoy the language learning
about the country the culture and and
even though you haven't really nailed
down the grammar and and what I tended
to do was I had listened to simple stuff
to begin with and then I went to more
difficult stuff someone asked me on one
of my youtube videos
is it worth listening to stuff you don't
understand no get stuff for you can
access the text if you can access the
text the transcript
bring it in to link as i did say the
words and phrases and that way you will
eventually be able to understand more
and more
anyway that was cases the second issue
is verbs of motion in Russia there is
one the word to go in English I go I go
tomorrow i always go
not in Russia aside from the fact that
the verbs have tenses and change for
tents and change for person
ok that's a minor problem bigger problem
is that him
if you go but they call
multi-directional you kind of go all the
time or going
come back that's one verb but if you are
going there
that's another verb and if you go on a
means of transportation
that's another verb and that also has
its multi-directional and uni
directional form and that's just for
goal and then there's Carrie and calm
and fly and swim very difficult to get a
handle on and to actually be able to
reproduce it doesn't prevent you from
understanding the language but it is
very difficult to nail it down when
you're speaking and then we have the
aspect of verbs and I should get that i
have read these definitions so many
times it's if the action is completed or
was supposed to be completed or might
have been completed or was never going
to be completed
then you use one form but if in fact it
was completed it might have been
completed and except for the other
exceptions that you use this other fuck
I don't understand it I've read them so
many times and here again is just
exposure and eventually because you
can't be trying to go through all these
logical explanations
while you're speaking so you to my mind
you have to expose yourself to a lot of
the language and then eventually starts
speaking a lot
ok i could get into other issues that
are different but they're minor like you
know the word for like in it we're okay
a get where but in Russian is also you
know from where to where I have two
different words that those are minor
issues
the big problems in Russian are the
three bugbears cases verge of motion and
aspects of hurt
now the good news russian is fascinating
it's a beautiful language the country is
fascinating their culture and history is
fascinating
the people who appear kind of so much
story in fact are very warm and they
dared to speak their minds and say what
they think
and don't worry too much about the
details but that's what makes them so
fun to be around and i would say to that
there is this
in Russia you know there's no compromise
and and I think that's how they approach
even artistic creation or sports and
that's why we see a lot of artistic
creation Russia outstanding ballerinas
outstanding musicians are never
scientists and even in sport you know
the certainly in hockey I find the
Russians are just the magician's their
artists and so they have a tendency to
really commit themselves in one
direction they're not they're not fence
sitters
so with that I'm sorry that I ran for so
long I could speak forever on the
subject it's been a big part of my life
the last five years all the less seven
but the last two i was on a moron check
and romanian and portuguese and whatnot
it's been a big part of the last you
know since my 16th birthday and will
continue to be so and I very much
encourage you to learn Russian
despite the difficulties thank you for
listening